gas prices we're at five bucks a gallon
national average california they may be
at 10 already uh at least they're
trending that way what is going on with
gasoline prices and how do you kind of
evaluate how high they could actually go
well they're gonna go uh this is
traditional of energy crises and we're
very much an energy crisis if you look
at uh how we define it at 42 macro
whenever you have a trailing two year
change of trailing to your doubling or
more of the crude oil price or natural
gas prices or gasoline prices which
we're very clearly observing that and
across all three of those markets uh we
tend to see that as an energy crisis um
and his the history of energy crisis is
actually not very kind when you think
about it from an economic perspective or
how they end because they typically end
because these are very inelastic uh
goods you know we typically you know
we'll demand we'll need them no matter
how what the high price is until you
really start to cut off the tails of
consumption
these things typically end when we start
to sort of um price people out of the
market unfortunately so we're talking
about low-income families middle-income
families just not being able to fill up
the tanks so there's been a lot of talk
of price gouging uh and then also there
is talk of the equivalent of shrink
flation there was a little controversy
on the show earlier today uh they're
increasing the amount of ethanol in the
gasoline how do you think about the
dilution of the gasoline like the
quality people are actually getting and
then how do you think about evaluating
are these gas stations or
gasoline providers price gouging versus
they're just responding to market
dynamics
no no they're definitely responding to
market dynamics and if you look at a
chart of crude oil prices
outside of the the grade that russia
ships i think it's called euros or
whatever uh don't get me don't call me
on that but anyway the prices are you
know rocketing to the moon wti prices
which is what we produce here in the
united states rocketing to the moon and
oh by the way just for folks who don't
know there's all these different grades
of gas of petroleum of crude oil um and
one of the reasons uh you know with the
us is is i think either the first or the
largest second or the first or second
largest producer of energy in the world
but yet we're also still i think the
first or second largest importer of
energy in the world and that's really
just a function of you know our grade
that we produce is very light it's very
sweet i don't know who the hell's he
drinking crude oil to figure that out
but
it's very light it's very sweet and we
need to mix it with a much heavier sour
grades of crude oil in order to put it
in your your car fill up your gas tank
for the engines to effectively work on
an optimized basis
so when you start to think about uh gas
prices i immediately jump to the fact
that certain portion of people
uh who have long commutes who usually
are lower income
gas makes up a much much higher
percentage of their monthly expenses
than you know some rich billionaire who
uh it's you know nominal amount of what
they spend on a month-to-month basis
is that a perfect example of like
everyone experiences inflation
differently
100
everyone experiences inflation
differently they experience financial
tightening differently and so when we
talk about things like you know
inflation pricing diff pricing out or
slowing consumer demand it doesn't just
hit like all in one month or is this
this one monolith it's a process whereby
incrementally as prices continue to rise
we price and price more families out
of from incremental consumption because
again it takes up a greater share of
wallet so discretionary purchases and
even some non-discretionary purchases
start to get curtailed at the margins
we're certainly already observing that
in the consumer spending data when you
look at um you know real pce growth is
somewhere we're tracking it around only
1.8 on a three-month annualized basis
that's below trend that's below our you
know sort of potential growth rate that
we've observed in the economy in the
past kind of five or six years um you
look at it on a goods you know goods
consumption is basically zero we've
we're no longer growing from the
perspective of consuming goods because
again energy prices food prices et
cetera are really pricing out uh
discretionary purchases and then even
services consumption you know at a this
with a one handle on it at 1.8 percent
through month annualize that's telling
you that very clearly the broader
sectors of the economy which is
consumption consumer is really starting
to slow down and feel the impact of this
stuff and so to answer your question yes
it impacts different families and
different segments of the income cohort
differently but it's not just energy
prices rising don't forget we have this
entity called the federal reserve that's
hiking interest rates and draining
liquidity from financial markets through
quantitative tightening and through
traverse repo facility and those that
financial tightening that we're
observing
in the equity market rising equity risk
premiums in the credit market rising
credit spreads that doesn't hit
companies all the same time at the same
time either you're going to have bad
companies or companies with you know
very risky operating budgets or high
fixed costs get hit sooner and harder in
other companies but ultimately it's
going to hit us all when you look at it
on an aggregated basis
when you think about this obviously
there's core cpi and there's a cpi
metric and they remove energy and food
does that change how much weight of
importance you put on either one of
those metrics uh when you see gas prices
exploding like this
yeah so let's start the core cpi is just
another name for that is convenient cbi
for policymakers right
let's strip out the stuff that goes up
the most whenever we have an
inflationary episode so we can make you
know make it pretend like we're actually
doing something about inflation or at
least doing uh it's not as bad as it it
otherwise would be um but when you're
talking about course so
whenever you're trying to get financial
markets right you need to predict the
things that the central bankers are
looking at and will respond to
irrespective of the fact that as i as a
human being who fills up my gas tank and
and eats
food very clearly are experiencing the
uh the inflation and the shrink
inflation that we're all uh kind of
pissed off about and again this one one
thing about inflation when inflation's
high it's the only thing you think about
it's the only thing you talk about and
obviously we've been talking about
inflation for quite some time in this
program and we'll continue to talk about
it for some time in the program but
anyway the point about core inflation
you always want to make sure that you're
focused on the things that the central
bankers are focused on so that you can
stay one to two steps ahead of
positioning for the liquidity cycle
dynamics that are that are important for
financial markets and on with respect to
core pce which is the fed's preferred
inflation metric which basically strips
out everything that
you and i would consume on a consistent
basis i mean it's it's a pretty uh
you know we don't need to get on the
index construction but you know that is
running at about just shy of five
percent at about four point nine percent
year-over-year now obviously you look
around that's a ridiculous statistic
house prices are up 20 year every year
you know energy prices are up let's call
it 100
you know the food prices are up you know
50 you know that's obviously a
ridiculous metric but again it's now
starting to move in the right direction
so it's telling you that inflation
momentum is really waning but the key
takeaway for investors is that the
momentum may be waning but the level is
still dangerously high from the federal
reserves uh from the function the
perspective of the federal reserve
reaction function
so we've got a chart here uh it's the
core goods cpi uh
disinflation explain what's going on
here and why you think it's so important
yeah so this is uh this is these two
charts go together this first one here
uh it's core good so so tomorrow for
everyone uh
not paying attention we're gonna get the
may cbi report coming out of the u.s
economy and sort of part of the reason i
put these charts together is there's
sort of a developing consensus in the
marketplace that inflation has peaked
its rolled and we're just kind of now
we're just getting closer and closer to
the fed finally you know giving up on on
policy tightening et cetera et cetera
we happen to have a very varying
perception to that view we don't think
the fed's anywhere near giving up policy
tightening and in fact when you look at
the inflation dynamics themselves which
we'll talk about here in this chart it's
not so clear that inflation may yeah
maybe inflation's peaked on your rate of
change basis but it's not so clear that
we've we're going to see a significant
disinflation a deceleration in inflation
in the coming months and the reason i
say that is because what if goods
disinflation and core cpi in this chart
the the up the top panel just shows the
index level of goods prices core goods
prices so obviously we've had a
significant inflation in core goods
prices the middle panel shows the year
over year percentage change uh in that
in that top panel and the bottom panel
shows the three month annualized
percentage change so we're still you
know very high on a year over your rate
of change basis in the middle panel but
we basically ground to zero um on a
sequential basis and so it's telling you
that that disinflation core good cpi
which is causing disinflation and core
cpi and core pce has been the driving
factor but the next chart uh which is uh
what if dot dot dot is overpowered by
accelerating core services prices and to
me this is kind of the one thing that i
don't think the average investor is
paying attention to which is the
potentiality for the disinflation in
core goods to get overwhelmed by the
acceleration in core services
same analysis the top chart just shows
the index level of core services um the
the the middle panel shows the year over
your rate of change and the third panel
shows the three month annualized rate of
change at around you know seven and a
half percent you know we're it's
building momentum to the upside in court
services prices and oh by the way
services is a much larger segment of the
of the economy it's about two-thirds of
the economy or two-thirds of consumption
sorry 75 of consumption two-thirds of
the overall economy and so you know if
we continue to see this type of
acceleration in services prices which we
should based on house price dynamics and
shelter price dynamics it's very likely
that inflation stops improving i.e
disinflating and decelerating in the
summer months and we might actually get
a pickup in inflation which will cause
the fed to get incrementally more
hawkish and markets to go down as a
function of that